قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه النظاميه حلت محل قوات
فاغنر في مدينه باخموت ولكن عناصر فاجنر
لا يزالون داخل المدينه
وكان مالك شركه
من المدينه باتجاه معسكرات خاصه وقال
بيروغوجنر ستتكمل انسحابها من المدينه
الخميس المقبل
في الساحه الخامسه صباحا يوم الخامس
والعشرين من مايو سنبدا بمغادره بخموت ومع
بدايه يونيو سننهي الانسحاب الى معسكرات
في العمق سنسلم المواقع لقوات وزاره
الدفاع وسنترك لها الذخيره
معنى
حسان مسعود ومن دنياتك مراسلتنا كارمن جو
خضار كارمن نبدا من هذا التطور المرتبط
بباخموت حول انسحاب قوات فاجنر وان كانت
القوات الروسيه قد بدات فعلا
ربما الانتشار في المدينه
نعم مريم كما كان متوقعا ووفق اعلان
مالك شركه فاجنر فان قواته من المفترض ان
تنسحب من هذه المدينه التي كانت قد اعلنت
السيطره عليها في العشرين من مايو وكان من
المتوقع ان تبدا هذا الانسحاب اليوم وهو
ما جرى
ومن هناك قال ان قواته ستبدا بالانسحاب
على ان تنهي هذا الانسحاب في الواحد من
حزيران المقبل وبالتالي هذه العمليه ستاخذ
بعض الايام يبدو اننا نسمع قصفا
مريم تكثف هذا القصف في الساعات ساعات بعض
الظهر ونحن خلال انتظارنا سقطت بعض
القذائف في المناطق المحيطه بهذا المكان
هذا من جهه ما يجري في دانياسك تحركات
ميدانيه على عدد من الجبهات في افديفيكا
وغيرها من الجبهات ولكن اليوم هناك فهم
روسي للتطور
الميدانيه التي تقوم بها اوكرانيا مجموعه
معطيات يجب قراءتها لفهم كيف تتعامل روسيا
وكيف تقرا هذه التحركات الاوكرانيه ترى
روسيا ان هناك محاوله لنقل المعركه الى
اراضيها قصف جديد نسمعه الان اذا روسيا
ترى ان هناك محاوله لنقل المعركه الى
اراضيها هذا كيف يمكن فهمه من تحركات
بالجروب تسلل هذه المجموعه التي اتهمتها
روسيا بانها مجموعه قوميه اوكرانيه تسللت
الى المنطقه هذه ليست الاولى بالتحركات
عند المقاطعات الحدوديه ايضا ما جرى في
اليوم في شبه جزيره القرم من مسيرات
اطلقتها القوات الاوكرانيه وهي ليست
الاولى بطبيعه الحال هذا ايضا يدلل على ان
هناك تحركا في اتجاه محاوله نقل هذه
المعركه الى الاراضي الروسيه الخليه التي
تحدثت عنها مريم في الخبر التي كانت
تستهدف مجموعه
خطوط امداد بالكهرباء وكان يمكن ان تؤدي
الى وقف المفاعلات النوويه ايضا مؤشر لهذا
المسعى الاوكراني يمكن القول وايضا هناك
مؤشر اخر اعلنت عنه وزاره الدفاع يوم امس
حين تحدثت عن محاوله لمهاجمه سفينه التي
تتواجد في البحر الاسود
ومعتبرته وموسكو اعتداء على هذه السفينه
وتعاملت معه بتدمير السفن التي حاولت
مهاجمه هذه السفينه التي تتواجد عند مضيق
البوسفور اذا اليوم هناك فهم جديد وتعامل
جديد مع كل هذه التحركات والتطورات التي
تقوم بها اوكرانيا بالتزامن ايضا مع
استمرار الحرب على مختلف الجبهات وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث عن قصف يمتد من شمال
خاركيف وصولا الى واخر سون في الجنوب
وبطبيعه الحال المعارك تستمر على عدد من
الجبهات في دنيات كوالوجانسك